xavier marrant il est secrétaire général
adjoint du syndicat national des
enseignements du second degré les aviez
marrant merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors un calendrier de
retour dans les écoles maintenu par le
gouvernement pour éviter le décrochage
vous rejoignez cette nécessité pointé
par le gouvernement disons que le
décrochage scolaire
il faut savoir quand même que les
professeurs que ce soit en premier ou
dans le second degré ont fait le maximum
avec leurs élèves en cette période de
confinement est malheureusement le
gouvernement court après un calendrier
qui s'est imposé lui même alors que il
aurait dû au préalable définir un
protocole de conditions sanitaires pour
pouvoir rentrer là il s'est fixé un
calendrier de rentrée est maintenant et
ben en quatrième vitesse
il est obligé de ceux de trouver les
moyens pour pouvoir mettre en oeuvre un
protocole protocole sanitaire qui est
nécessaire et essentielle pour garantir
la sécurité à la fois des élèves et des
personnels dans les établissements
scolaires on va y revenir au protocole
sanitaire mais selon vous ce retour à
l'école
il est davantage pour répondre à une
crise sociale qui s'amorce on peut
penser notamment à certains jeunes qui
pourraient être laissés livrés à eux
mêmes
ou alors il doit répondre à une urgence
éducative
non mais ça le l'urgence éducative et le
palier aux difficultés scolaires des
élèves c'est ce que le gouvernement met
en avant alors que on sait bien qu'un
des objectifs c'est quand même pour le
gouvernement la reprise économique et
donc le problème c'est que il ya un
certain nombre d'élèves et qui du coup
doivent retourner à l'école de quelle
sorte que leurs parents puissent
derrière allait aller travailler
mais le problème qui se pose pour le
retour à l'école et là on voit bien
qu'ils précipitation de la part du
gouvernement
c'est que aujourd'hui
les conditions sanitaires d'un retour à
l'école ne sont pas garantis dans toutes
les écoles et par exemple cet après midi
quand le premier ministre annonce que le
mal le masque sera obligatoire quand les
règles de dispensation sociale ne
risquent de ne pas être respecté dans
les collèges par exemple cela ne nous
rassure pas non plus
non cela ne rassure pas le problème
c'est que là le gouvernement à reculer
par rapport à ce qu'ils avaient
proposées au départ au départ les
masques devait être obligatoire dans les
établissements du second degré donc ça
c'est une excellente une excellente
chose tout le monde devait porter des
masques bon et là maintenant on voit que
hercules et ils tergiversent en disant
non mais les masques il faudra emporté
lorsque les distances sanitaires ne
pourront pas être être respectée mais le
reste du temps il y aurait pas nécessité
de porter des masques non nous on n'est
pas du tout d'accord avec avec cette
orientation par ailleurs si le ministère
a bien dit que les personnels et ça
c'est quand même la moindre des choses
que les personnels de l'éducation
nationale allait bénéficier de masques
qui serait distribué par l'état pour les
élèves il en est tout autre c'est aux
parents de fournir les masques pour
l'heure pour leurs enfants et on voit
bien là et vous l'avez dit dans un
certain nombre de vos reportages que les
masques et bien c'est un coût financier
non négligeable et le fait que l'état ne
puisse pas donné des masques pour les
peaux les élèves dans le cadre de
l'enseignement scolaire alors que
l'enseignement scolaire est censé être
gratuit
c'est quand même un véritable souci
alors du coup comment le corps
enseignant aborde cette rentrée du 11
mai ce qu'on peut s'attendre à un droit
de retrait de la part de certains
professeurs évidemment on peut
s'attendre à un droit de retrait de la
part de certains professeurs parce que
d'abord le lin le retour à l'école des
élèves et des personnels ne posent pas
se faire comme ça d'un claquement de
doigts le ministère voudrait que ça soit
en une demi-journée en une journée que
tout soit prêt pour pouvoir accueillir
les élèves
sauf que réorganiser les cours faire
ensemble que
on définisse comment on peut se passer
l'accueil des élèves quand il doit y
avoir que une quinzaine d'élèves par
classe et encore pas dans toutes les
salles parce que toutes les salles font
pas 50 mètres carrés bref
et puis comment va se passer
l'enseignement présentiel d'enseignement
distanti lcd bref toute cette
réorganisation de l'école des collèges
et des lycées
c'est quelque chose qui doit pas se
faire en si peu de temps
il faut laisser du temps au personnel
pour pouvoir s'organiser après on a un
certain nombre de personnels qui
effectivement sont assez inquiets ils
vont devoir prendre des transports sauf
que les transports en commun lien il ya
des des mesures de distance yesil même
de distance sociale qui doivent être
respectées donc tout le monde pourra pas
prendre les transports en commun comment
vont faire les collègues pour se rendre
sur leur sur leur lieu de travail là
dessus rien et rien n'est dit rien n'est
préparé sérieusement
donc oui à une inquiétude de la part de
nos collègues bien entendu merci
beaucoup vous aviez marrant d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire général adjoint du
sns est sue le syndicat national des
enseignements de second degré